we're going to get Trump versus Biden
again like if you told me right now hey
you have to put money down on the debate
and this is what I would say to you guys
I'm curious what you guys think about
this what's the number one worst thing
about Biden from an election 2024
perspective number one weakness
agent I think Cena I think it's age
overwhelmingly right so to so many
people cosmetically make decisions on
who to vote for
78 year old that's how old he would be
Donald Trump on the stage against 82
year old Joe Biden number one reaction
people are gonna have is both these guys
are too old Trump even though he's far
more in control of his faculties and the
fact that Biden can't even speak the age
thing gets canceled out if Trump is the
nominee I mean I would just say I told a
big Republican donor just a few nights
ago we had we had dinner and uh down in
down in Miami and they asked me what do
you think I said um I said I will not
throw in for either side either
privately or publicly I won't I'm not
I'm either DeSantis or Trump whoever
wins and I'm very open about that but I
said if you're asking me for odds as to
who's gonna win the primary I'd give you
two to one odds that Donald Trump wins
the primary
I agree with him 100 on that and then
the second part of this is
if you put DeSantis or Nikki Haley or
somebody younger on the stage against
Biden I think those people win big
because a lot of people out there just
look at it and say we can't have a
president who's 82 years old
like Joe Biden legitimately could could
Joe Biden do any job at your business
yeah I I think it's even more it's even
more specifically than you know Joe
Biden that's the perception the
persuadables right like I'm voting for
what I'm voting for because I've
believed in the same basic principles
since I was a teenager effectively in
the Constitution all this kind of stuff
right but for the people that could go
either way or could show up or not show
up the age thing with Joe Biden I think
could be big because remember they're
not they're not one-issue voters on the
economy or the Border or anything else
they're kind of thinking about a whole
range of things and they look at this
guy and he's I mean it's it's kind of
sad I mean he's decrepit right but what
we've seen with fetterman is that that
will not stop them one bit that will not
stop it comes down to juxtaposition if
you've got a 78 year old guy an 82 year
old guy it's like they are they've
already been around the block a million
times there were known Commodities
everybody knows them you get a young
fresh Ron DeSantis on there
juxtaposition versus an old sleepy Joe
it's going to be alarming to Moses
that's why I said trial by combat the
benefit Republicans have is they know
who
is going to be a nominee and that's how
Biden got selected they knew Trump was
going to be in the ring and they said
he's the less dangerous by the way I'll
build on what Buck said we've got such a
big audience on radio you asked the
question about endorsements
um we don't ever want to be in the
position of hey you should vote for this
guy or that guy in a primary we're
obviously going to be a billion percent
behind Trump DeSantis Nikki Haley
whoever the nominee is because Biden is
such a disaster right and so that's
where we really kind of murder I spent a
lot of time reminding because in our
audience uh on radio we have people who
are calling in saying you guys are way
too pro-trump and we people calling in
who are saying you're way too Pro
dissenters and they also something I'm
never gonna listen again you're too Pro
Trump or two pro to Santa every day
every day we're getting we're getting
this from both sides and I try to remind
them if you're a trump guy you're a
DeSantis guy you are someone who
probably agrees on 90 plus of everything
happening in America today you're on the
same team you're just trying to figure
out who the captain of the team is going
to be that's going to get a little lost
during the primary I know it's big boy
stuff I understand that but I hope that
people keep that in mind as we go
forward here um because you know what
you don't want is to get in a situation
where someone is so damaged and and you
know so hobbled from the primary that
they actually kind of Limp into the
general right before Trump runs as a
third party which is everybody's worst
that's the worst scenario scenario so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]